Oh all ready to go but I'm gonna try one
more thing I wanted to work this out and
I was reminded cuz you got a white girl
yeah no I know he's good with it that's
why I had to feel him out first you know
I mean you do look like you got a high
like white woman outfit on though you
got you got the Michael B Jordan from
Black Panther hair with little [ __ ]
you got glasses on so you don't look too
dangerous you got a nose Pierson let her
know you're adventurous I guess but good
for you man love who you love you know I
guess it was very important for me to
marry an Indian girl because I'm like I
know this is weird but I'm like really
like Pro indie like I'm very proud to be
run like militant about being brown and
I know it's funny I get it but I just
thought it would look weird if I wasn't
with an Indian you know I mean I cuz I
had two roommates in college it's true
they were like the text book militant
black dudes who only dated white women
swear this is a real thing you know dude
in the back is laughing he knows him and
it doesn't look weird man and they
always walk around they go [ __ ] all
these white folks there's a real sense
he probably said it
yeah if you do that [ __ ] they do that
exact [ __ ] man [ __ ] all these white
folks and then they would go [ __ ] all
these white folks a little weird
and then wrong but it looks a little odd
optically it just looked off you know I
didn't want to do that
so it was important for me that my for
my wife's brown but I did start to see
the appeal as I talked to them more and
more like I still got black friends the
day white women I'll try to like bond
complaining about significant others I
go man oh you hate it when your [ __ ]
girl is yelling at you all day for no
goddamn reason just in a bad mood taking
it out on you and they literally be like
I've had this exact sentence no Janine
doesn't believe in conflict
doesn't believe in conflict conflict as
my girls love language
um if my girl went a week without
nagging me for no reason I'd be like let
me see your phone [ __ ] will [ __ ] you
nagging that's not me huh let me see
I'll burn this whole [ __ ] house down
don't think you're gonna cheat nag on me
[ __ ] and get away with it
I got Stockholm Syndrome man that
sentence you start to understand things
man start looking at white women like
iPhones if she liked you hey man
I might have to make that switch damn
just so user friendly hey I just got a
update a murder once in awhile and they
give me no problems I mean yeah sure
they're all starting to look the same
but whatever nope I stuck with my
Android
my non-compliant ass high-maintenance
ass always giving me problems as can't
even take this [ __ ] on a plane without
worrying she gonna blow up in my arms as
brown girl all right I'm gonna get going
my name is Akash then god bless
[Applause]